y licencias de pesca que enfrían la
diplomacia horas después de expirar el
plazo dado por la unión europea completa
año otorgó a un grupo de licencias de
pesca adicionales a los barcos del
bloque continental que les permite
pescar después del break sit en aguas
territoriales británicas la reacción de
la dirección comunitaria no se hizo
esperar
la decisión de hoy es un paso importante
en un proceso largo de la plena
implementación del acuerdo de comercio y
cooperación varias embarcaciones que
buscan acceder a estas aguas aún no
reciben licencias
la comisión europea continuará
trabajando junto con francia para
asegurar la implementación de los
acuerdos y examinará las circunstancias
legales de cada solicitud que no se haya
otorgado a pesar del consentimiento el
gobierno británico justificó su posición
tenemos embarcaciones con licencia donde
se ha proporcionado evidencia suficiente
que demuestra que el navío califica para
el acceso donde no se ha proporcionado
esa evidencia no se han emitido
licencias francia acogió con beneplácito
el otorgamiento de autorizaciones y
recordó que ya se han obtenido
previamente mil 34 licencias el 93 por
ciento de las solicitudes además
enfatizó que estaba investigando las
vías legales necesarias para asegurar
los permisos restantes
la disputa por las licencias se remonta
a la salida del reino unido- del bloque
comunitario parís argumenta que no se ha
entregado la cantidad de autorizaciones
que se le debe mientras que londres
subraya que solo entrega los permisos a
los barcos que puedan demostrar que
trabajaban en esas aguas con
anterioridad la pesca representa un
porcentaje mínimo en las economías de
ambas naciones pero figura como un tema
sensible en lo político